we already did this once it went well it
went amazingly well and I was very sad
that we couldn't put it out because we
had technical difficulties this time
we're both in our home setup no
technical difficulties and we're going
to run it back
from what we got through last time plus
more
well last time I was also very sick that
night uh after we were I recorded a
podcast I did the podcast with you so
two podcasts in a row and I went home
and basically just was in bed with a
fever for the rest of the night so uh if
you thought that was good great uh
because I thought it was terrible and I
was feeling terrible at the time I got
it I gotta do better than that okay
maybe that's just what all guests feel
like once they've finished up recording
with me that's what I like the post
title like depression that occurs after
you've podcasted with me I'm not too
sure I'll have to ask some previous
guests all right so I want to go through
some of your most controversial or
semi-controversial opinions which you've
kind of become famous for I think first
one one of my favorites hard work is
massively overrated why
well I'll take a step back the reason I
like these controversial opinions is uh
a you always look cool if you have some
controversial opinions uh but B
I I'm
I've learned how much of what we believe
is just simply stories that we're told
um this goes from
everything religion to uh school to
being taught what you should be doing
for your career and all this stuff and
so I've actively tried to just deprogram
myself and ask and question the
Assumption so I actually started with
looking at what are the things that
almost nobody disagrees with and are
those really true and one of those that
I found that I in practice disagree with
was
growing up I was told hard work is
what's most important hard work is the
key to success hard work is and you just
hear hard work preach and it's almost
like you'd have to be insane to be
um
anti-hard work right like some people do
it just for the just for the effect but
I don't I don't really being like that I
just mean it's overrated it's not that
it's a bad thing but that it is
overrated because what I found in my
life is that what you do is far more
important than how how hard you work on
that thing so for example you know I
thought about the hard work thing and I
used to work in restaurants and
nobody works harder than people in
restaurants restaurants are open you
know from breakfast till till late night
every single day seven days a week it is
uh you know a thankless job you were
working in a hot kitchen
um and you are you know Cooks work hard
Cook's in the back line of a kitchen
work hard janitors work hard you know
the cleaning lady works hard
um but you know you sort of think about
you're like why isn't the janitor
driving a Bentley right like if hard
work was the key to success then why
aren't the people who I think works work
the hardest in most these situations
doing better
um and it's because you know hard work
will let you win the game that you're
playing
but it doesn't help you if you chose the
wrong game and so the most critical
decision is actually project selection
what you decide to work on uh what you
decide to do with your talent and your
time and your your work ethic is far
more important and I don't really hear
that in fact I actually growing up heard
the opposite
um you know you get to college and
they're like What's your major
uh I don't know I'm 17 18 like how am I
supposed to you know I just came from
high school right like I don't I don't
know what the thing is yet
um is there a list I can look at of like
the jobs and what they're like can I do
do I get to go see one
um you know instead it's just like just
pick if you don't pick if you don't
declare if you don't declare your major
this is in the US at least I don't know
how it's for you if you don't declare
your major you're behind like already
it's like you if you've chosen
to wait and see or think or go test
you've fallen behind right so it just
became this thing where picking what you
do was like this quick one second thing
you were supposed to just get right
right away with no preparation
and then spend the rest of your life
working hard and I just found that the
opposite actually turned out to be true
for me which was picking the right
project made the made a huge difference
and working hard enough was good enough
I consider myself to be frankly somewhat
lazy but very happy and successful so
you know I you know I don't know if I'm
the outlier or what but like at least
disproved it is not um
it is not the main thing in terms of
success I believe it's overrated yeah to
clarify here I don't think that you're
saying hard work doesn't matter hard
work isn't a competitive Advantage
you're saying that for the people who
believe that hard work is absolutely
everything it is the end-all be-all that
there are other higher points of
Leverage that you can do that open up
layers uh levels and and layers to the
hard work so that it can be maximized
yeah exactly hard work is Maybe
the fourth or fifth most important
factor or ingredient
um so you might say uh what what's more
important so number one to me is what
you work on number two would be who
you're around who who you work with
because those people will
influence you in a far greater Direction
and provide more opportunities in the
future so what you work on who you work
uh who you work with far more important
than how hard you work I sort of think
it's something like fourth or fifth most
important on the list and that that
really there's just a threshold you need
to reach so
um if you simply don't take action you
don't do the work it doesn't matter how
good of an idea you had or how good of
Partners yet obviously not gonna work
but um it is a threshold and that going
far beyond that threshold going from 40
hours a week to 70 hours a week to 90
hours a week like some people will will
popularize
um
has much less of an effect than I think
people think it just sounds good sounds
cool and it sounds like you earned it
yeah why why is it if if you're true if
what you're saying is correct and hard
work is as overrated as you say it is
why is it such a pervasive myth
it's virtue signaling most people
um you know the reality is if you looked
at um like a contribution a chart that
showed the contributions to success well
I was born with like all my healthy
functions right yeah 10 fingers ten toes
everything works great
um I was born in the United States so
already that was like far more
influential in my future success and
Endeavors than uh you know somebody who
had a you know the genetic Lottery
played out differently for them they're
born in a different place with a
different set of fiscal resources
um and you just keep going down the list
of like how uh what you what what
actually contributes to success a lot of
those things are out of your control I
can't take credit for where I was born I
can't take credit for the genetics that
I was given or the gifts the talents
that I had uh as a baseline
um
so what people try to do is they try to
shove those away pretend those don't
matter because you didn't earn them and
people will say you're privileged if you
if you bring them up and so instead they
go to the thing that sounds like they
made a choice to do it and that is the
sole reason why they had the success
that they had I chose to work hard I put
in the time I earned it and it's sort of
like you know the same thing happens in
uh in any any Endeavor
um when I win it's because I'm great
when I lose it's bad luck so why is that
why do we think that when we win it's
because of what we did and when we lose
it's because what everybody else did
right what the what the economy did what
the weather did what the uh you know the
government did like you know people are
very quick on the downside to offload uh
accountability and on the upside to load
in accountability so just notice these
things notice human Nature's Tendencies
and realize
it does seem like that would be the
convenient thing to do uh to assign
credit to your actions and to make it
sound like you if you if you have a lot
if you earned a lot if you got a lot of
success the reason why is because you
put in a lot and in reality we know that
sometimes it's asymmetric sometimes you
just make a few critical decisions
simple decisions I might have taken you
a very short amount of time to do but
totally differentiated between success
and failure yeah I think there's a few
things going on
um one being if you achieve success and
it wasn't painful people who are working
hard and suffering and haven't achieved
success to you to them you just look
like a wanky sort of Bourgeois
Aristocrat of some kind like a a
Randomness Aristocrat that was blessed
by this this sort of chance
um Sam Harris has got this idea that I
didn't get chance to bring up with him
on our episode The Myth of the self-made
man and he takes this one step further
because he folds in determinism and a
lack of Free Will so he's basically like
none of the things none of the
achievements that you have are yours to
Bear because you didn't choose the
circumstances you didn't choose the laws
of thermodynamics he didn't choose your
genetics he didn't choose the randomness
he didn't choose anything and he uh sort
of aims this at the right and says this
does an awful lot of heavy lifting for
people right of Center and uses it to
kind of lambast this this myth of the
self made man the problem that I have
with that is it's a very disempowering
story to tell yourself I I don't see it
as an Adaptive or useful story like I
want to feel pride in my successes
because otherwise I know that I'm not
going I'm going to leave more on the
table because what's the [__] point
like I get satisfaction from doing
things well so it's almost like uh it
might be a literal truth but a
figurative falsehood in that it's not
adaptive to believe even if it's true
and I think that I don't know maybe
there are times when self-deception can
be justified and that might be one of
them
100 agreed
um on both of the points you made so I
think the first is that uh you know
if you were honest about what actually
works and what doesn't it might annoy
people
um because if they have it hard if
things are going poorly or it's hard uh
they wanna nobody likes to hear uh how
easy it was for somebody else or how
simple it could have been if they had
made different decisions uh so it's sort
of like Keeps The Barbarians at the
gates type of thing to be like no no the
reason the only difference was I put in
more time in this direction and you put
your time in this other direction you
know and it's the most
Equitable way to describe this uh that
pisses off the least number of people
however for me pissing off people is not
really
a priority or a concern I'm not trying
to do it nor am I trying to avoid it I'm
just simply trying to be and let the
chips fall where they may if you some
people will love it some people will
hate it and that's okay
um I don't really care too much either
way
um the second point you made which is uh
there is no you know the complete myth
of the self-made band is it is
disempowering and so um I have this
whole category of things that I always
say are maybe true but not that useful
so for example if it's true but not
useful there's plenty of things like
we'll be in a meeting at work and
somebody will say something I say that's
that's true I don't argue with what
you're saying but it's simply
unimportant it's not useful to what
we're trying to decide or what we're
trying to do here similarly if it is
true that we sort of have no Free Will
and that it's all determined anyways and
that doesn't really matter what would
you do well that's not that useful
because it doesn't actually serve me
that's not a story that serves me and
once you realize that it's all just
stories anyways pick the ones that serve
you pick the ones that make you feel the
way you want to feel that get you to the
outcomes you want to have and and not
the one that make you feel like crap a
related Point another opinion of yours
what are the most underrated skills in
the world right now in your opinion
so I have two the first one people don't
even think is a skill which is how
underrated it actually is is
um enthusiasm
sort of a lame maybe a little bit of let
down from the way I I framed that but uh
I don't think it should be a letdown I
think it should be exciting that
enthusiasm is underrated I'll give you a
little story
so I had a realization one day so I was
24 years old and I took a job it's like
I moved to Silicon Valley to take this
job I joined the company and I think at
the time I was probably the youngest
employee in the company about 20 people
there I was the youngest of 20. and um
and I looked around and there was
engineers and there's designers people
with all kinds of talents that I did not
have couldn't code couldn't design uh
you know can't dance can't do a lot of
things right so it's a not like don't
feel like I have a bunch of hard skills
and I was like what am I good at all
right you sort of have that sort of like
imposter syndrome self-doubt moment
where you're like what why do they have
me here why do they put me in charge of
this project is it because I literally
give them like you know
and I and I realized that like one of
the things that I had that turns out to
be quite important for most
people who go on to do interesting
things
is I had a lot of enthusiasm meaning
I was very excited about what we were
doing I would paint a picture that was
compelling to me and then I would Sprint
at it and the ability to paint a picture
that excites you
the ability to bring excitement to a
situation sounds cheap sounds fun sounds
totally frivolous until you're around a
group of people that don't have it and
then when the first person comes in that
has a bunch of enthusiasm that has hope
about the future that brings energy to
the table it's contagious it changes the
way everybody feels and if you're going
to do something that's important
generally it's hard right I come from
the world of entrepreneurships
Entrepreneurship people sort of realize
like yeah it usually starts off like
you're starting from scratch you have
nothing trying to make it happen there's
a lot of force of will that goes into
that and discipline is one force of will
I'm gonna show up at the right time and
do the right things the other is
enthusiasm which is I'm gonna believe
before it's here and I'm gonna believe
that it's gonna happen I'm going to take
that I'm going to borrow on that future
excitement today I'm going to take out a
loan against the future and I'll borrow
my happiness and excitement about the
future and I'm going to deploy it today
to invest that that enthusiasm today
that's how I think about enthusiasms
borrowing from the future and
um
I think it's a skill I think it is
massively underrated I think having
enthusiasm when things are going good is
quite easy having enthusiasm when things
are neutral to bad is where you get the
value of it and um most things are hard
and most things have pretty deep dips
um so having enthusiasm is I think
completely underrated because people
don't even see it as a skill they don't
see it as something you could develop
and they see uh and they don't place the
importance on they don't realize how
important that source of fuel is how
contagious that is how it brings
everybody's level up when you have it so
I think that's underrated I'll tell you
the second one is storytelling I want to
go I want to jump I want to jump in on
enthusiasm two things by the way three
or disagree
uh I have noticed since I've been in
America I've realized the value of
people around me being excitable the
British are genealogically like we are
genetically predisposed to be kind of
dour uh sort of personality is very
similar to the weather it's sort of gray
and everything's a bit [__] um but we're
very great with the satire and the
sarcasm and the cutting the cutting
remarks and stuff but my disposition
doesn't need any more of that and what I
realized one of the reasons that I
flourished since I've been in America is
I've been around people who believe that
things are going to be better than
they are right now they continually
presume progress is baked in it it's
factored in all the time that things are
going to get better because it's going
to grow oh dude it's going to be fine
this catastrophe you're going to get
over it and everything that may be
America overall I'm not sure that may
just be my particular cohort of
particular people in this particular
City that I'm living in
but what it's done is it's raised my
ambient mood an awful lot
um
we do not know the things that are going
to happen in the future right we are not
Clairvoyant we don't even really truly
know ourselves we're self-deceptive
other people deceive us we don't have a
crystal ball that shows us what is going
on either outside the world or inside of
our own minds and our own bodies
given the fact that we have to have some
form of delusion
Why not pick a delusion that's going to
be beneficial to you right like you have
the choice to do this why ER on the side
of and the only real reason I've been
railing against cynicism for quite a
while now and it was Michael malice's
book the white pill that really got me
onto it cynicism is the opposite of
enthusiasm in some regards and
what I realized is
the people who were being cynical were
doing it because it was like sour grapes
at an existential level I called it the
cynicism safety blanket that if you
presume that things are going to be
terrible you can never be disappointed
by the world exactly and it just seems
like it's like a coward's way to live
and I understand I understand people
have had bad things have happened to
them they've gone through traumas
they've had discrimination they've had
all of this stuff like don't I get it
right I understand and that would set
you up to believe this may very well
happen in the future but like
what does it do for you what con does it
grow show me the corn that you're
growing from this the corn you're
growing is [__] shitty so yeah I
think less cynicism more enthusiasm the
skill two questions you can respond but
two questions as well
how do you develop it as a skill and how
do you feel it effectively let me
um let me give you a couple different
angles of this okay so I come from
Silicon Valley and Silicon Valley the
cynics get to be right and the Optimus
optimists get to be rich
um so the cynics get to be right that
you know eight out of the ten things are
gonna fail of course yeah you were right
you get to be right eight out of ten
times and the two out of ten that
actually work
you sat on the sideline thinking it was
just another thing that's not going to
work so Silicon Valley Silicon Valley
retrains your brain so one way to train
your brain to default optimism rather
than default pessimism is to play in the
game where optimism gets rewarded and so
come to Silicon Valley you get to play
again uh the up against broader here's
another here's another angle where it
comes from this great Conor McGregor
quote I love it used to be my desktop
background I told the story before I
came to silica Valley and uh every
engineer has like multiple monitors it
was like a status symbol like they don't
have Louis Vuitton or the status levels
like how many monitors you have how
elaborate is your desk setup so I'm
sitting here with just my laptop and I'm
like [__] I got the I'm like the you
know I'm I'm wearing the the thrift
store version of of this luxury style
idiots kid at the party exactly I didn't
even know what I would do with another
screen but hey I need another screen
here it guy come on let's go so I get
another screen and I don't know what the
hell to do with it and so I just put up
one quote because I was like I don't
have any functional you like there's no
functional utility here aside from
again honing this skill of enthusiasm
I'm controlling my mood and the quote
that I had on there was a Conor McGregor
quote where he said they were like
Connor you always have this personality
and even when you lose you seem to be
having this like I feel like we never
get to see you you know down in the
dumps and this is usually a sport of
highs and lows and he goes
at the end of the day the quote is this
at the end of the day you got to feel
some type of way so why not feel
unbeatable why not feel Untouchable why
not feel like the best to ever do it and
I just love that quote which is
I'm in any moment I am going to feel
something I'm going to be feeling a
certain type of way
and I think what a lot of smart people
do is they try to make that neutral
because it's just like almost logically
mathematically rationally makes sense
it's like well I'll make my default
emotional home to be neutral feeling
nothing and as good things happen I'll
feel better and as bad things happen
I'll feel worse and this is like a
unspoken thing that I see a lot of smart
people do a lot of intellectuals do this
it is like a neatness and starting at
zero and then I'll go up if you're good
and bad if it goes down whereas people
with the self-delusion and which are
usually if you you get to sit down with
like kind of people remarkable people
every week
you'll notice that their emotional home
is not zero their emotional home is
closer to ten they default feel
Untouchable Unstoppable unshakable they
just enjoy that feeling and they just
start there and yes sometimes the world
will beat them down a little bit and
they'll dip but they'll everybody always
returns to your emotional home and so
you have to like program it set that
like a temperature like a thermostat in
your room what is my default temperature
going to be and I I just took time to do
that um so that's the first thing the
second thing is here's enthusiasm in a
non-business context
um anybody who's ever dated somebody
knows that like there is the
quote-unquote honeymoon period like the
start of every relationship that you get
into
um is typically where it's like you know
the highs the you know both people like
I always say a first date it's like two
people sitting down and deciding to lie
to each other it's like you present your
best self you're going to
um you're going to basically play
everything up you're gonna your
gentleman how genuinely are you you're
gonna play it up here let me get that
door for you let me let me dress up let
me do XYZ you know nobody farts on a
first date and so
what happens is later in a relationship
uh people will Retreat back to their
emotional home their their personality
home
um and all of a sudden they'll start to
behave differently somebody you know at
the beginning let me take out that trash
at the you know at the end why I always
have to take out the trash why don't you
do whatever you know for once once in a
while
um so we we kind of slip and we slip in
these ways and the worst way we slip is
that the enthusiasm dips uh we get
comfortable and the enthusiasm dips and
the kind of the classic Trope here is
like when
um if you see somebody come home from
work you see like a dad come home from
work
this person you know Dad might have been
left left the house at six in the
morning seven in the morning worked hard
all day drive back home sit in traffic
for 40 minutes get back to the house
open up the door they're hungry they're
thirsty they're tired they put down the
briefcase
take off the suit jacket finally and
like they sort of slump through the door
and what all they want to do is get to
the couch get the cold beer turn on the
TV and turn off their brain and this is
how like I think a lot of the world
operates
and I heard this once and I never let it
go which was that if you
if you if you do what you did at the
beginning there would never be an end
and um and there's Works in
relationships if you act the way you act
at the beginning there would never be an
end in the relationship because both
people would be on their absolute best
behavior giving to each other uh all the
time and the version of this that I try
to like make as a practice or a habit is
to have honey I'm home energy so honey
I'm home energy is like have you ever
seen I Love Lucy back in the day the guy
opens the door he's bursting with energy
like nobody comes home from work like
that but this guy did it in the show
because it's a show he would come home
honey I'm home and you can just hear
from the voice if somebody's in the
house oh get ready it's on like get
ready for a great ball of energy coming
your way that is going to be loving that
is going to be affectionate it's going
to be playful and flirtation is a
Charming all the things we kind of want
to be
um but we we slip and we don't do it and
so one simple practice to develop the
skill of enthusiasm is to have this
honey I'm home energy which is before
you walk through a door whether it's to
a meeting whether it's to your house
your apartment whatever it is
just decide to walk in with that honey
I'm home energy and you only need to do
it for like 45 seconds but if you just
do that for 45 seconds you'll like the
way it feels they will respond to you
differently and it'll just carry
um versus if you come in slumped over
you're going to have that type of energy
and that type of interaction those types
of experiences which nobody actually
wants to have we'll get back to talking
to Sean in one minute but first I need
to tell you about HubSpot look I spent a
decade and a half networking with people
and following up with them and ensuring
that the messages that you send are well
crafted is such a crucial part of that
and hubspot's free follow-up email
template guide is absolute gold for this
it's got over 30 email templates
covering everything from a simple thank
you to asking someone out for a coffee
without seeming too weird one of the
best ones that's in there is they're
sharing resources template if you ever
come across a valuable nugget of
information from say listening to this
podcast perhaps or anywhere else on the
internet you now have a template to
share it with other people which in my
opinion is a really underutilized
networking skill because it gives them a
gift for free and it keeps you in their
mind I highly recommend that you
download the 100 free follow-up email
template guide by going to the link in
the description below or click
hubspot.com
lnx that's click hubspot.com lnx or the
link in the description below yeah the
enthusiasm or excitability portion is
it's almost kind of like
a personality trait that I didn't know
about it's like finding out that there's
a new type of weather you just step out
one day and you're like what the [__] is
this oh I've never seen this before it's
like that right and um yeah I I very
very much I'm completely Pro I've been
calling it toxic positivity I'm very Pro
toxic positivity like just seeing seeing
the good in situations being around
people that do the same there's
definitely an undercurrent in the UK of
um excitability almost being naive it
being uh kind of immature it's being
lame
um and then you know even as you move up
through the the IQ distribution smart
people like the idea of being cynical
because it seems heterodox and it's it
it seems like you've considered all of
the options only somebody that's a you
know a smooth brained idiot would
believe that things are going to go well
yeah obviously you know that's what
that's what that's what the Normie
midwards think no no I I've considered
the options
um but it fails to recognize that all
ultimately
your experience of your life is largely
determined by the story that you tell
yourself about it in fact you could
maybe say that it almost it's almost
exclusively determined by that there's a
thing called the so people talk about
Vicious Cycles and we've seen Vicious
Cycles how people slip into depression
how companies fail how vicious cycle a
vicious cycle for example would be if
you break it down into its core elements
there's just three little it's a
triangle three dots triangle dot one is
belief if I believe that something is
not going to work this relationship is
not going to work this company's not
gonna work this meal is gonna suck
whatever whatever it is if I believe
that it's not gonna work
the second dot is actions how much
action am I going to take
towards making it happen right like I'm
going to take minimal action because I
don't believe that it's going to work if
you don't believe it's going to work you
just sort of tiptoe in you're not
actually gonna like Go full full force
on it so minimal belief leads to minimal
action which leads to a minimal result
which only reinforces your shitty
original belief and that's the Vicious
Cycle so then the next time
you just reinforce that oh you know um
I don't really believe I'm gonna stick
to this diet
so therefore I'm not actually gonna like
throw away the junk food I'll just put
it away in the closet a little bit and
therefore I'm gonna actually end up
snacking on the stuff because I know
where it is it's in the closet it's just
I just have to open the door and then I
get a shitty result and I say I knew it
I'd never follow through with these
things right like these are the stories
you tell yourself silently in your head
the voice in your head
and the opposite is true there's also
the winner cycle or The Virtuous cycle
the virtual cycle is the exact opposite
massive belief oh my God this is going
to work what if you knew that like if
you knew that if you get to this like
you're what you're going to the corner
store and if you knew at that corner
store there is the winning lottery
ticket it is there the next person who
prints it wins
would you would you walk or would you
run right like you're going to run so
your belief if you really believe that
you would take Massive Action you would
Sprint and when you sprint you would
actually get there first right and like
you would actually have a different
result than you know Lottery is not
exactly right because you're not gonna
the belief is ill-founded in that case
but you would take Massive Action and
generally Massive Action over a
consistent period of time leads to
results which reinforces your belief
that I'm the type of person that
whenever I set my mind to something I do
it and when I do it I get results right
like that that just becomes how a winner
thinks and so enthusiasm is another word
as a sort of a it you know roommates
with belief and if you say belief
beliefs are these kind of like heavy
long-term you only have a few beliefs
enthusiasm is a general state that you
operate in such that it takes your
default level of belief in something up
which takes your action up which takes
your results up over time and that is
sort of like the this and to me the
strategy that under that explains why
this works not only does it feel good to
have positive enthusiasm or positivity
but like there's an actual Advantage I
think there was a TED Talk Back in the
Day called The Happiness Advantage and
this guy was talking as a Harvard
professor and he explained that like
happiness is not just doesn't just feel
good it literally makes you perform
better they did many tests to see how
you actually perform on the same same
test if you came in in a certain State
versus a different a different state the
Happy Happy State versus not yeah George
Mack has this really great idea that I'm
going to write an article a code written
article with him about of um uh public
metrics and hidden metrics and he talks
about stuff like peace of mind being a
hidden metric but money being a public
metric and time is very interesting
times somewhere between the two we kind
of don't know time but we kind of do as
well uh so for instance people will
happily sacrifice that peace of mind in
order to achieve money because there's
no dashboard that tracks your peace of
mind and it's almost like enthusiasm
right enthusiasm is such a hidden metric
uh as opposed to it being something that
you fail to see the cost of it's
something that you fail to see the
Returns on uh because the the inner
texture of your mind is not something
that you're open to so that's people
will learn another language they'll tick
a box oh I'm gonna learn Spanish
um versus work if you said I'm gonna
work on upping my general level of
enthusiasm you'd be looked at like an
insane person what's going to actually
serve you better in life we need to do a
lingo we want to do a lingo for
enthusiasm yeah I actually I prefer the
opposite I am happy to be the one who is
massively exploiting this Arbitrage
captain or capturing all of the games
exactly that's a talented talentless guy
like me thrive in a world like this
right okay second skill what's the other
one storytelling
um so stories are then storytelling is
is massively uh underrated because
stories are the natural
um like transfer mechanism between
individuals so like if you want
something to stick in somebody else's
head you really have two choices music
or story
um
and you know you look at like through
all of time what are the things that
have lasted thousands of years
um religions how are religions coded do
you remember all of the all of the rules
of religion no but people remember the
stories
um same thing with you know anything
that lasts a long time or sticks in
people's heads uh you know I couldn't
tell you what I learned in seventh grade
but I could tell you the plot of Lion
King uh you know a play-by-play plot of
Lion King why because it's encoded as a
story so stories are like an encoding
mechanism for for information or for
knowledge music is another one people
will naturally you know uh remember
catchy music uh most people don't have
the ability to make music but almost
everybody could tell a good story so uh
if I could do the music thing I would uh
but instead I'll do the story thing and
I think this is underrated because
um and I think you know Steve Jobs had
some quote like this he's like um
uh something like the Storyteller is the
most powerful person on Earth because
they get everybody else to take action
so uh they're the ones who move one
person to the next and this is how
politicians get people this is how uh
CEOs run companies and stories and so
um
but you're very rarely taught how to
tell a story like if I went and asked
somebody
like just explain to me like how if I
wanted to get better at storytelling
what would I do like what what what are
the skills like give me like the two or
three big Concepts and so they're very
uh uh nobody really knows how to
articulate it you're not taught this in
school and um because of that again
there's a massive Arbitrage you have a
thing that is quite it is very valuable
that most people don't know how to do
very well so if you even try a little
bit you'll become the top 10 one percent
of storytellers very quickly and from
there you know you get the sort of
results that a great communicator would
get what are the principles of
Storytelling as far as you're concerned
so if you listen to like um Aaron
sorkins the guy you know the the writer
and movie guy who did you know I think
he did like whatever West Wing and
Newsroom and a bunch of other stuff like
The Social Network movie
he's like if you ask him like I wanted
to take his master class I had set out a
day I was like I'm gonna learn
everything there is to know from this
guy about storytelling because this
guy's a master Storyteller I cleared my
calendar and like in the first 30
minutes he just repeats the same one
principle over and over again I'm like
oh that seems to be it uh which is
stories are about intention and obstacle
he says I worship at the altar of
intention and obstacle so basically
if you watch any movie you watch any TV
show within the first second you will
you you should know right like at any
given time you should be able to pause
and you'll know this usually within the
first five minutes of every story
There's a Hero and the hero wants
something they have an intention and
they have an obstacle what's in the way
of it
um last night I was watching a show
called hijack you've seen this it's on
that yeah I finished it did you finish
it I finished it last night oh yeah
everyone should go and watch it
right away you see Idris elbow well I'll
I won't spoil it but Idris Elba wants
one thing right at the very beginning is
he wants to be with his family
and he's got some obstacles wife doesn't
want to be with all right so like you
get that if you go watch Die Hard Die
Hard oh it's this movie about defusing a
bomb and doing it let's create this
terrorist plot what does he want at very
beginning he gets a call he wants to be
home with his family
but then there's this terrorist plot and
really at the at the end of Die Hard all
he's trying to do is just get to his
family like the whole movie is hero
wants something and there's something in
its in his way in this case a terrorist
plot
um and so and then throughout any story
that escalates so like let's take uh
this show hijacked right the name kind
of gives it away a plane gets hijacked
Okay cool so now this person wants
something different he doesn't want to
you know bring his family back together
he immediately just wants not die from
this terrorist right or not die from
this hijacking land safely now that's
the intention what are the obstacles
well there might be people working
against that plan and so every story
must have at its underpinning and
intention and obstacle okay that's the
first key principle of Storytelling and
um it doesn't matter if it's a romantic
comedy oh what does she want well she's
a high-powered lawyer but all her
friends are getting married and she's
not dating anybody what does she she has
an intention she wants to remember he
wants to have a loving relationship the
obstacle she's so successful in all the
guys she meets are [__] okay cool
she's busy and happy tassels
okay now what do you do to to make a
story more compelling the next
ingredient you need to add is steaks so
you sprinkle some steaks on there what
are steaks steaks are elevating the
what's at stake if they don't get it so
intention obstacle if the intention is
I'm hungry and the obstacle is you know
lunch is over there in the other room
it's not that exciting of a story
if the stakes are
this person hasn't eaten in 30 days and
they're you know if they don't eat
they're gonna die right like now all of
a sudden you have something more
interesting so steaks are how you
elevated now Stakes don't always have to
be life or death the best story some of
them some of the best things like I
don't know if you've seen this show
called The Bear that's out recently it's
on uh it's on Hulu and it's cool it's
just kind of like critically acclaimed
like cool people think it's cool type of
show
and in that there's not life or death
Stakes there is no terrorist plot there
is no like uh life on the line but they
know that for everybody in a in whatever
your world is there's something that's
the highest Stakes thing the thing you
want the most and all you have to do is
convince the audience that this
character really cares about this that
the character really feels like it's a
like a life or death it's a
life-changing swing if it happens or it
doesn't happen so all you have to do is
make it believable that that that's the
case so when I tell stories
um I do I actually take both pride in a
story where on the surface the stakes
are small like I told the story once at
a corporate retreat it was like an
executive Retreat and they went around
the circle and everybody's supposed to
say what's going on and everybody was
trying to one-up each other with a more
import a bigger problem a more urgent
fire that they had to put out and I went
the other way I said
so I just moved out of my house uh into
my own apartment this was back in the
day I've just moved out of my house my
own apartment living on my own for the
first time and my mom is coming over now
my mom's coming over and I had told her
that like I'm living on my own I'm a man
now I'm a big boy now I can do it but
the reality was I was still you know
like clothes are all over the floor
house is a mess I don't have groceries
nothing but I told her I'm cooking
dinner for tonight and I'll be damned if
I didn't look like an adult for at least
two hours while my mom is there and so
I've established the intention I've
established the obstacle right I'm
trying to look like an adult obstacle
I'm not actually an adult Stakes my
mom's opinion of me matters to me I can
convince you that it matters I convince
you that like
drop everything I will not fail at this
I will it will be so bad for me if this
happens and I talk about in the story
I'm like you know I and this is true
really I made brussels sprouts because
that was the most adult thing I could
think of
um YouTube I'm trying to figure out how
to make brussels sprouts taste good I've
never even eaten brussels sprouts and
like I tell the story people loved it
they loved it because I took a low
stakes thing and I told a story well
um I love that that's really really
great and yeah I say this a lot but
aspiring fledgling podcasters that ask
me about sort of what I wish I'd known
when I started the show and there's all
the technical stuff and all of the
Strategic stuff that's good for growth
hacking but when it comes to the show
when I first started doing it I thought
that the job of a podcaster was to
basically be blinkist for your guest
that you were supposed to ruthlessly
index whatever's in their head and that
you any moment that was Meandering away
from it any sentence that wasn't
directly driving some sort of uh return
that people could action in their life I
basically wanted to be Andrew huberman's
website dictated right to people but but
for everybody on the planet and over
time it increasingly I've realized that
the best podcasters are just five
Architects they architect the vibe and
all that they're doing is they're just
allowing you to marinade in that Vibe
you know today's Vibe is here are some
contrarian thoughts that you may take
offense to but you're probably going to
find interesting and we're going to
Whimsy our way through a bunch of Side
Stories before I decide that it's time
to move on to the next one that's the
story right that's that's the vibe for
today so people know what they're going
to expect and I love these listical
style articles in particular because it
keeps everything quite Snappy and it
keeps it moving and it stops everything
getting to but it's not about being like
right Chan I need to know the five-step
process on storytelling and then I need
to understand exactly how to do the
whatever
it's good because it focuses you to make
sure that you get something out of a
conversation
but allowing someone to meander and
let's not forget I've sat down opposite
Rogan uh a lot of my friends have
multiple multiple times that man is a
like he's like a cook for Meandering
like he is in love with Meandering and
it works amazingly on his show because
it's it just feels so naturalistic
because that's how you talk with your
boys oh that's how you talk with your
girls right when you sat at the dinner
table or out having a beer or you've
just finished playing pickleball or
whatever someone sees a a particular
type of bird guess what the next 15
minutes are about birds like and then
the next five minutes after that are
about how birds are actually a psyop
from the government and I saw this
Conspiracy Theory online and oh what
about Australia remember you've seen
that thing that Australia doesn't exist
and that's a sign up yeah actually my
aunt went to Australia I've got a friend
who's doing rattlesnake conversion
therapy because rattlesnakes are turning
gay but due to East regions in the water
how do you think that Alex Jones trial
is going in isn't he the most suit
person and you're like it just Frank
pictures and branches off it's like
Freestyle rapping but really slowly and
I think that that
protracted just allowance of I'm gonna
follow the Curiosity it it keeps people
who have got varied interests interested
because it doesn't it doesn't pigeonhole
you too much it's a natural
representation of how people have normal
conversations and even if you sit down
to try and have a normal conversation
with someone and then you began to
constrain it everyone would feel the
constraint
like I've Got a Friend really famous
comedian who sat down for dinner with
Jordan Peterson this is a long time ago
now it's the first time he met him and
now he's become friends the first time
he met him he had notes he tried to have
a conversation with Jordan and
apparently halfway through it was like I
need to like stop [__] about with
these notes like I'm not I'm not here to
interview I'm not the New York Times
right The Washington Post he'd just have
a conversation with the guy and guess
what like if he had a bad flight that
morning you're talking about flights for
20 minutes and that's fine and yeah I I
Vibe architecting storytelling Whimsy
really leaning into it like you know
unnecessary detail like cold blustery
November night all this [__] like yeah
get in there I love that I love that
yeah I think it's uh podcasting is a
medium that allows for that that's the
beauty of it
um not other mediums you can't do that
you can't Meander in a tick tock in the
same way but you could do other things
in a tick tock which are very
interesting
um like you can say nothing in a tick
tock and it works as long as you had the
vibe right there too have you seen this
girl who did this uh
what the [__] do DJs actually do video
that went viral you ever see this no
what is it oh my God we need Jamie here
to pull this up for you okay so this is
Tick Tock because this girl I think
she's a model she's she's just looking
at her phone like she's like very close
to her phone it's not even like a staged
whatever it's like she's just look at
her phone and she's she's like crying
there's like a tear going down her cheek
which is inexplicable because all she's
saying is she's like almost like uh
broken down she's like what the [__] do
DJs actually do like what are they what
buttons are they pushing what do the
buttons do is it even connected to
anything and she just she did that and
it was so funny
it was not trying to be funny but it was
so funny she was saying nothing but she
was it was the whole vibe was there
because immediately she was like
somebody who was so shook by this like
this unknown and this like realization
that I don't even know I don't even
understand this thing and I think it
might even not even be real are we sure
that this is real
and it went viral now and then a bunch
of DJs started doing it turned her
saying that into a sample and turned it
into a song so they're turning it into a
a song and um
and then she came back as she came back
on also like the very next post where
she was like so many DJs are answering
me about what DJ's actually doing now
just got me thinking what if what does
footballers actually do I mean like are
you guys just running around like she's
like almost flirting like yeah yeah yeah
maybe you guys should slide into my DMs
now and tell me what you do because that
other one worked so well yeah it's but
she gets Tick Tock in a way that nobody
does I think like she's gonna be a
superstar I watch a bunch of her content
and it's because she is a Vibe architect
there she knows how to be
at her house doing nothing
while still entertaining you and making
you feel like you know her
like she did this like kind of like Girl
Next Door hot thing right like she's hot
enough that Tick Tock is interesting
but she's makes it feel like she's not
trying she's related feel relatable yeah
and she's talking about nothing but
she's entertaining when she the way she
says it so it's this like amazing like
mashup now Rogan does the equivalent of
that for podcasting or he's like he gets
a good guess but not like celebrities
really like it worked when it was like
his friends who are good hangs he's like
then we're gonna talk about stuff but
we'll kind of go wherever
and we could talk about nothing but you
still are entertained and you still kind
of learn something because we talked
about a nothing subject that you knew
zero about
um and so you know he gets you that way
so I find this stuff very very
entertaining are very interesting how it
all plays out it's not how you would
have thought
um and I'm sure many people told him
like dude three hours way too long for a
podcast
um cut it down trim it out edit it make
it 40 minutes that's the length of a
commute yup and he was like I'm just
gonna do what I want how about that and
I like it I remember when I first
started doing podcasting and I looked uh
you know
run everything by the data okay so
um what is the optimal length for a
podcast well if you want to maximize
completion and balance that with value
you're looking at it's between sort of
30 and 40 minutes I think because that's
the length of a commute you want people
to be able to commit to it during a
commute it doesn't account for those
Psychopaths out there like me and
probably you that listen to stuff at
like 1.5 or 2 or 2.5 times speeds it's
like that's like double commute or
whatever but um yeah and ultimately it
comes down to are you having fun because
if
enthusiasm with storytelling enthusiasm
plus storytelling or enthusiasm about
your story is a vicious combo me and my
house might always talk about this these
uh Riley cro not rallycross what's the
is it Motocross or rallycross rally
driving like off-road rally driving
thing like Holly McRae what he used to
do
um there are these guys that wear anorax
and it's the Scottish Highlands and it
is the middle of October and it's pitch
black and freezing cold and they've been
camping there and they stand there by
the side of this dirt track to see 0.25
seconds of a cargo past
that's it and then they turn to all of
their boys and they're like
and they can't believe it and watching
anybody get fired up that much about
anything
fires you up as well this is why
enthusiasm is contagious and this is why
toxic positivity and going against
cynicism is good because it has a
trickle-down effect right like a
contamination Zone from a nuclear spill
you've got this Fallout that just
continues to go and it can happen on the
internet
and it's this girl this girl was
genuinely so intrigued and found it so
funny
to to observe this thing like what do
DJs do and I've employed them for 15
years and it's still a question that I
can't give her a definitive answer to
she's under something what the [__] do
they do and so yeah I think very very
good okay next one if you're in your
head you're dead what's that mean
I guess there's kind of a theme with
these which is
um
smart people do really dumb things and I
think
um an example of that is people who are
in their head a lot so if you're in your
head you're dead I heard that once and
it just resonated with me partly because
it Rhymes I'm a simpleton but also
partly because there was something that
was very true about it and I didn't even
fully understand it yet but I was like
yes what though yes and what that was my
reaction to it which is a very good like
signal for something you want to know
more about which is an immediate
visceral yes without the intellectual
understanding yet
and what I learned from this was a very
simple thing I want to be happy like
many people do
but I did something that most people
don't do which is trying to figure out
how the hell do you actually be happy
and one of the things about actually
being happy is that you need to get out
of your head so
most people who are
again the type people who listen to
podcasts I'll call out with a lot of
people who listen to podcasts they are
in their head they try to think their
way through life they think their way
into they think their way through
problems and that serves them but then
they think they can think their way
through feeling like they want happiness
so they try to think their way there
whoa no no hold on
you can't you know like that's like
saying I'm gonna talk my way through
cooking no no there's two different
things like I can maybe think my way
like in logic my way through logical
problems but I can't think my way
through emotion that doesn't that's not
how emotion Works trying to think your
way out of overthinking is like trying
to sniff your way out of a cocaine
addiction George Mac
dude George two bangers in this episode
I love it he's great I just added by the
way I just added George to my work slack
even though me and George don't work
together because I was like I just need
more George in my life so we just have a
channel in fact we're like I'll just
dump random [__] like this and he'll
he'll do the same it's amazing highly
highly recommend
um
so the the the realization here was I
always had a mindset I thought the
formula worked like this I thought if
you
um think a certain thing you will feel a
certain way which will lead you to do a
certain thing and that is true if I
think that this person is
um this person just cut me off while I
was driving
I will feel pissed I'll feel angry and I
will then do something in retaliation
I'll road rage I'll drive I'll cut them
off I'll flick them off whatever it is
right think leads to feel leads to do I
thought it's a one-way Street and I
realized most like like math equations
math equations are like reversible like
if a plus b equals a then C equals a
plus b so the other way also works and
it actually works better in this case so
if you do a thing you will feel
differently which will cause you to
think differently and so anybody who
exercises knows this intuitively whether
they've wrapped words around this or not
which is uh
if you if you focus on if you think so
if you think you're feeling tired or
shitty and therefore you um you know if
you think I don't have enough time or
I'm feeling I didn't sleep enough last
night whatever you'll feel tired and
shitty therefore you won't do exercise
but if you just happen to overcome that
if you if you quickly just short circuit
that and say nope not listening to that
thought and you instead just go do the
thing you go and you get do 50 push-ups
right now on the ground you go into a
cold plunge you do something physical
you will immediately feel different
which will lead you to have a different
thought and um and so once I realize the
equation works better the other way the
street the traffic is less crowded going
driving the other way on that road
I was like this is the hack and so
um now I realize that the thoughts are
not the sort of Master controller of the
universe they're just an equal party to
this they have one seat at the table
feelings have another and actions have
another
and actually they all influence each
other so if you want to feel differently
you can either think something different
or do something different and doing is
just way easier because if you try to
think yourself out of it you just tie
yourself up in knots usually and so once
I realized that realize this I realized
I had lived a lot of my life in my own
head trying to think my way through
everything at a much faster version of
this was to just do something this plays
itself out um in a bunch of different
ways so one time I saw on Twitter
somebody say something like
I've been having panic attacks or
anybody found a way to you know get
myself to not have these panic attacks
and they were like therapy or you could
try just you know really talking
yourself through it so you're not
feeling that you don't think that
thought therefore you don't have that
feeling therefore you don't have the
panic attack
and then Emmett Shear who's the CEO of
twitch the guy who had acquired my
previous company uh replied to it and
this was I never really thought a CEO
would chime in on like hey here's how I
deal with panic attacks but he did and
he goes uh fastest fastest hack for
panic attacks uh immediately dip your
face uh submerge your face into ice cold
water
um you will stop having the panic attack
immediately because it activates the
mammalian dive reflex yep and I I never
heard this before I just completely new
to me but it was exactly in the same
line of thinking which is often the
fastest way to change how you feel is a
rapid change in your physiology which
then will lead you to think a different
thought which then will lead you to feel
a different way and have a different
action it's just a hack it's a just a
complete Life Hack That most smart
people don't utilize they're just brains
sitting in a dead vessel and you see
this go go watch how people operate they
just sit in their car sit on their couch
and sit at their desk or like you want
to make a you want to have a meeting
where you're going to make a key
decision they might change the
trajectory of your entire company and
everybody sits there hunched over tired
after a long day eating shitty food full
of muffins yeah yeah trying to get a
coffee just to stimulate themselves just
to kind of get through that thing it's
insane we make decisions when we're in
that physical state it is it is a uh an
absolute leak or weakness in most
people's game one of the interesting
things I learned from Kelly starrett's
supper leopard guy was if you've ever
had to take a really mentally
challenging phone call what you will
sometimes find yourself doing is like a
puppeteer has got a hold of you you'll
stand up from your seat and you'll start
locomoting around the room you'll just
do laps you've got a 30 square foot room
that you're in and you're some you've
somehow managed to create some totally
arbitrary route that you're walking in a
figure of eight or an infinity symbol or
whatever around this room we're just
built to move humans are built to move
we're built to be on the ground we're
built to be out in nature we're built to
be connected to the the ground to see
Sun etc etc this you don't need to go
full like Aubrey Marcus psychedelic woo
like biohack Ben Greenfield biohack
stuff here like it's just it's notice
within yourself what your physiology
feels compelled to do
when things happen to you like you do
something you reach for something
because the cookies or the cinnamon
rolls or the coffee or whatever is in
front of you and you've conditioned
yourself to think that that's the thing
what's that's going to change you
huberman's got the best quote on this
which is you cannot change the mind with
the mind you have to change it with the
body I don't know if that's strict as
with most aphorisms there's exceptions
meditation is purposefully changing the
mind with the mind right like it's it's
actually isolating the mind to cycle on
itself but I think that the broad rule
is very true and I've always said this
that if you gave me the choice between
having a good night's sleep or going to
the gym
I will go to the gym every time and my
mood will be reset more
from pre to post training then from pre
to post bed right I can wake up and
yesterday's bad mood or whatever can
bleed through the night I'll have a
dream about being kidnapped by people
from Liverpool and being forced to do
their marketing or I had that literally
happened a couple of weeks ago
I also had another one where um I'd
committed a war crime and my old cricket
team from 20 years ago knew that I'd
done it and they were mercenaries
hunting me and Sam Harris was a
newscaster trying to track me now
speaking of Sam the episode that I did
with him he had this really lovely bit
where he's he's talking about kind of
this um
like cerebral pornography that a lot of
us have where we sort of pray at the
altar of cognitive horsepower and um and
and presumed it because we've got such
good Concepts that we can just you know
we can we can sort all of this and when
you when he tries to explain to his
smart friends that meditation and maybe
letting go of that and and finding a
little bit more ease releasing the
tiller a little bit more might be a good
idea they say well that sounds roughly
equivalent to being hit over the head
with a hammer you know I I look at all
of my great Concepts you would have a
much better life if you had some cut you
should have more Concepts like mine like
imagine how great you'd be if you had my
concept right and it's yeah I I it's a
permanent battle I think and you're
right as well to point the finger into
the ears of the people that are
listening to podcasts like mine and
yours because you're so good at this uh
you just told a funny vulnerable the
story about being adapted forced to do
their marketing is so funny to me by the
way that is [__] amazing and uh and
then you like connected the dots to some
like Sam Harris like you have this like
Bank of quotes and Frameworks and
nuggets from the smartest people on
Earth that's so amazing that you have
that so first of all you're good at what
you do I appreciate that thank you uh
the second is I had a realization while
you were talking that I think is a a new
philosophy that I have I I just realized
let me try to work this out live
um mental minimalism so basically I
think it's becoming Vogue to have a sort
of minimalist lifestyle maybe fashion
style like minimalism is in in a bunch
of different areas one area where it's
not in is mentally so
um the sort of knowledge porn worshiping
at the altar of the cognitive cognition
um collecting you know mental models and
Frameworks like their stamps like you
know I think a lot of this is complete
wasted energy and actually
counterproductive
um you know it's what's that Bruce Lee
thing it's like you know I don't fear
the man who knows a thousand kicks I
fear the man who's practiced one kick a
thousand times
same same the same Seas you know like
that's how I feel about like I really
just want to understand a few principles
and that's it how do you know which are
the right principles
um I think there's the I think they're
the ones that resonate and they'll still
change over time so like at any given
season of your life you need different
there's different principles that will
speak to you
um almost in a like when the student is
ready the teacher appears type of thing
um
right now in my life I think that there
are certain ones that uh that stand out
more than others but this mental
minimalism thing I think works because
it ties into my favorite meme the uh the
midwit meme The Yours Mine and George
Max George is ask him about if he's
going to do it uh the midwits Guide to
Life
so I haven't heard that he's he's
thinking about doing a uh coffee table
book which is every page is a different
midwick Meme and it's just just all of
them I mean first customer you know
whatever Kickstarter I'll put I'll put
author whatever it is that Meme I I told
my business partner at the beginning of
the year I said that's this is the meme
of the year I said this meme explains
everything I've done wrong in life and
everything I've done right in life when
I did it right I did it right according
to this meme when I did it wrong so if
people don't know the meme it's
basically I'll actually I think you
might explain it better than I do can
you articulate what is the midwit meme
and then let's let's play with that a
little bit of course yeah so it's an IQ
distribution which is a bell curve right
so you have a graph and from left to
right you have stupid on the left and
you have super super smart on the right
you have this bell curve that runs
showing that there's more people in the
middle than there are on the edges on
the left you have this guy that kind of
looks a little bit like a neanderthal
with this sort of furrowed brow and sort
of these sort of recessed eyes he looks
kind of thick and then in the middle you
sort of have this woke sort of sjw
screaming very tense kind of like
glasses stressed out guy and then on the
right you have the sage who almost looks
like a
Jedi Jedi Master or whatever and usually
you have both people the stupid and the
smart person end up coming to the same
realization and the person in the middle
has some over complicated idea so one of
the obvious examples would be
um lift weights eat protein stupid guy
guy in the middle I must ensure that my
pre-digested grass-fed coffee butter is
perfectly served 30 minutes before to
ensure that my protein window lift
weights eat protein right Georgie's
Georgie's favorite one of these is
um the guy on the left says I'm the guy
on the left the guy in the middle says
I'm the guy in the right and the guy in
the right says I'm the guy on the left
that is good there's levels to the
midwit meme I'm now learning
um I think that Meme explains someone
much of life I think that most people
should strive to be
uh you know the funny thing you could
strive to be either the neander all
Neanderthal or the Jedi doesn't matter
they come to the same conclusion
um and
this idea of mental minimalism can you
distill down why you're doing something
to one reason
people love pros and cons lists and they
tie themselves in knots trying to weigh
this out the scale of one pro one con
two Pros one and a half cons and they
and they can't make any decisions or
um this happens to me a lot in the
business world I I talked to a Founder
today they're starting a new company and
I said your last company was so
interesting you raised 20 million
dollars you did all the stuff you did
some good things but it obviously didn't
work out that's why we're here uh versus
on your yacht so
um so what'd you get wrong and you
proceeded to talk for 20 minutes telling
me about everything he did right and I
was like what happened I asked you a
question I said where did it go wrong
you gave me 20 minutes which already is
an incorrect answer because the answer
should be simple
um and then the 20 minutes were weaving
through things you did right and things
that other people did wrong and things
that other companies tried and what are
you talking about
people don't even learn the right lesson
from what they did and so like you know
I would simplify a lot of the things in
life right they like the diet part of my
life eat real food not too much exercise
right like that's it right um um eat
real food mostly veggies and exercise
this is this is diet advice at the
simplest level
um all I need to do now is intensely do
that thing right the difference between
knowledge and wisdom knowledge is
knowing what you should do and wisdom is
doing what you should do like to me that
is my definition of wisdom
it's knowledge applied it's doing what
you should do
um
you do need enough knowledge to at least
know roughly what you should do but what
most people do is they then over index
on knowledge and go try to learn all the
possible things that there are to know
about the subject and under index on
wisdom which is actually doing and
applying that the the base knowledge
that they have yes so trying to take the
mental minimalism thing uh making it a
little bit more applied I think that it
makes me think a little bit about the
explore exploit framework which is that
you need to be able to expose yourself
to enough ideas that you can work out
which ones are good which ones are bad
Tim Ferriss has a phenomenal idea which
is his system for memorization and it's
called the good [__] sticks and what He
suggests is you know if your Tiago Forte
and your or Ali abdall and you're built
from like that cohort of people
you'll have a perfectly organized
Evernote external brain that's got
everything's root folded and decision
treed back to whatever whatever
if you listen to something and it stands
out to you and you can't not send a
screenshot of it to someone from a book
or screen record it and send it to your
friends or put it in a group chat or
write it down in a note yeah that's good
that's good the good [__] sticks and um
that that for me is the easiest way to
remember stuff because you don't ever
have to remember things that you're not
excited about remembering it's easy to
remember stuff like the one that I've
got from you earlier on today that uh
cynics get to be right and optimists get
to be rich money Beyond money right I
can't forget it I can't I'm gonna
remember that now for five years right
I'm gonna be quoting that in in half a
decade's time can't get rid of it it
doesn't matter if the if the story about
storytelling if you've switched off and
you started thinking about like what
you've got to do later on today or what
you're going to make for lunch or
whatever like sweet then you don't need
to go back and try and remember that
because it wasn't for you right and
that's you know you just enjoyed the
lovely warm tones of what we're going
through so explore exploit good [__]
sticks good good that's so we've got um
how do I expose myself to it how do I
allow things to pop up like what's my
selection criteria from the things that
I've been exposed to so that's a nice
little framework to to run ourselves
through and then I would maybe say
when it comes to like stopping yourself
praying at the altar of cerebral
horsepower quite so much
all of the people that I know that are
the most effective in life have a very
small number of operating principles and
one orientation usually
one single orientation and this is a
lesson orientation what do you mean by
that they're moving toward a a
particular destination I hesitate to say
goal because I don't think it's quite
the same as a goal it's more an area
that they're moving toward so for
instance for George
um his would be
he wants to be able to have fun and
write so his entire life is built around
him being able to have fun and write
wants to write for two hours every
single morning it doesn't matter where
on the planet he is and he wants to have
fun and fun for him can be from hanging
with friends it can be doing cold cold
tub it could be learning to play
Pickleball it can be traveling it can be
doing whatever right
uh two stories one from Jeff Bezos
apparently while he was at Amazon every
single decision that was made was run
through one single orienting principle
that orienting principle was does this
improve the customer experience
does this improve the customer
experience every single decision don't
know if it's true symbolically it's
useful second one Elon Musk does this
get us closer to Mars does this get us
customized and if you have a single
orienting principle evidently does me
taking a poop now or taking a poop in 15
minutes time which one gets us closer to
Mars like that's you know you're not
going to ask yourself that question but
just having that orienting principle and
this is why uh homozy who is uh got an
interesting approach to this he talks
about periods of Life uh phases
phases or periods of life
um and he was talking about for this
next phase or for this next period and
it breaks them up into seven year blocks
he was like I know that I'm going to be
in Vegas for the next seven so I don't
mind like I can just lock in I'm in
Vegas this is this is what we're gonna
do we've got the apartment I've got I
know where I'm going to buy an office
and I'm going to do the whatever and I'm
going to build a gym
um
by having phases or periods of your life
it allows you to be more ruthless with
your
orientation principle because you don't
it doesn't need to scale for quite as
long if you accept that you're time
bound on what you're doing at the moment
I actually think seven years is [__]
insane like and obviously he's probably
got it broken in the 90-day Sprints and
one year blocks or whatever whatever
but by having it at least time-bound
what it permits you to do is be like
right okay all that I need to do within
the next 90 days is build up a healthy
eating habit and my social life can go
out of the window and my business might
take a little bit of a hit but I've
decided in advance that this is the
thing that I'm going to do and I like
the orienting principle as like a a way
to simplify down I've been exposed to
all these ideas some good ones have
stuck about the ones that I enjoyed are
the ones that I've I've kept now what
what am I really really aiming towards
okay which one spoke to me the most how
does it fit with my lifestyle and how
can I time by time bound that for the
next however long
yeah the time thing is interesting
because
um
you can use it in a bunch of different
ways you can play with time in a bunch
of ways so
when you think that something's going to
be really hard you shrink the time to
time box to be like cool what's the best
I can do in the next 45 minutes
and all of a sudden the brain becomes a
I call the brain an answering machine
you just have to figure out what the
right questions the right prompts like
AI what are the right prompts I need to
give it in order for it to give me a
different answer ask a better question
get a better answer and so uh you get
time box on the short scale to be more
productive to be more creative you can
time box like you said to depressurize a
decision so you can think uh in both
directions what I'll do sometimes is say
what if I was long like how do I take a
longer term term uh orientation towards
this so for example
I might say
um there's a meeting on the calendar I
don't really see the agenda it doesn't
tie into this thing I'm doing right now
but like over a long time Horizon I
think Chris is awesome and I want to do
awesome things with awesome people in
the long run great it's worth doing or
you know this person I could kind of win
more in this deal now but maybe if I
give a little it actually builds some
good will with us and it lubricates the
next 10 deals we do together I met a
friend once
um
I really wanted to be an investor and I
had no money and he was like
um
so first I just didn't do any deals
because I didn't have the money I just
was limited by my imagination don't have
money don't do deals and I missed three
Deals I became billion dollar companies
and at that point I was like okay well
I don't want to really see number four
so I'm gonna find a way I still have no
money but I'm gonna find a way so I
asked a different question in my brain
how can I invest even though I don't
have money brain says well you got
friends with Buddy why don't you ask
them uh why don't you why don't you do a
deal with them take a little less
economics but at least you do the deal
and immediately go to a friend who's
maybe 10 years older than me or so seven
seven to ten years older and um he's got
money and I said want to do this deal he
said yeah I said okay well I don't
really know
what's the fair split here like is there
a standard I'm Googling I can't find it
I don't want to be a sucker but I also
don't want to be greedy and I don't know
the answer and he I thought well this
and this guy's a business shark so I'm
like certainly he's gonna shark me with
this offer I gotta prepare myself for
this shark attack this guy's been so
successful made hundreds of millions of
dollars he is I'm playing chess against
Magnus Carlson here trying to negotiate
this deal with this guy
and instead he texts me and just says um
uh whatever you think is fair is fine
with me in this deal I actually don't
care about this deal what I care about
is doing deals with you for the next 20
years
and I was like huh never had a text
message like that never even had an
experience like that never met somebody
who takes that long-term orientation
Bezos and others have they I think Bezos
donates a lot to the long now Foundation
which is like this in San Francisco
there's a clock that's like 10 000 year
clock or some [__] like that it's like
this this tells you like think longer
think bigger
um you'll operate differently than
somebody who's always short-term minded
so you can go in that direction
or you could shrink the time Horizon and
say
you know what I don't know the forever
answer of my purpose in life and what I
want to do with my career and all the
stuff but what I do know is like this is
fun right now I think it'll be fun and
why don't I just set
two years what's what are great
decisions I can make though I'm happy to
commit to for a two-year period but not
necessarily a 20-year period so you
could depressurize the situation and
allow yourself to think more clearly my
buddy Sam has a version of this called
worry time and he's kind of like I'm a
pretty laid-back guy he's a lot more
like high strung in general and I'm like
how do you live like that he's like oh
I've found my mechanism so he goes I
have something called worry time he's
like I used to worry all the time about
whatever it is money my car repair
whatever whatever's going on
he's like and I realize like that really
doesn't get me anywhere
um to have this like low ambient worry
at all times this low-level non-specific
stress at all times he's like so I just
started setting out time I said okay I
don't think about I don't worry about
money except for Sundays from 11AM to
noon and that's my time I know it's
there and I'll think about money during
that time and I'll say do I have enough
and am I spending too much and whatever
and I'll make some adjustments I say I'm
good till the next Sunday and he's like
that's what I do I literally just
schedule it in it and just the fact that
I scheduled it of like now is the time
I'm gonna work work on this or worry
about this
um totally changes my like allows me to
then function freely and think clearly
other than that I love that hack Justin
Mayers has a similar one about choosing
what to work on he's like a common thing
you see is people get to a certain point
like middle of their career and then
they get paralyzed they can't decide
what to do they're looking for the
perfect project that's the perfect
conditions that's just going to be like
sufficiently ambitious and prestigious
and Noble and uh lucrative and all these
things and they just don't know what to
do they can feel totally lost and he
goes uh one of the big things that works
is basically committing to something and
being like I'm gonna not question this
decision every day
um my trainer says this thing he goes
you don't plant the seed and then dig it
up the next day and say are you growing
like no you plant the seed and you just
water it you just water it you just you
you know that that plant is going to
take a little time to sprout you that's
okay you don't dig it up every single
time and question it and so
um let's get this sort of scheduled
worry time or scheduled commitment times
I think
I think people are mostly victims to
time and then you meet some people that
are sort of Masters of time they
manipulate time in a different way and I
didn't even have language around this
until I met them and I started to
realize oh there's some games you can
play with time that actually make it
work for you versus just this thing
you're running out of and don't have
enough of next one people think they
learn from failure but I don't find that
to be true why
uh it's another one of those things that
everybody says and you sound crazy to
disagree with it
um
everybody says oh I failed but I learned
so much right I didn't lose I learned
right and these are it's a great mindset
to have
if it were true it is simply not true in
most situations because you if you press
on that you ask about it so what what
did you learn
answers not at the tip of the tongue
okay let me give you some time let's
think about it
okay so what did you learn right I gave
the example of the the founder who I
said well it failed why did it fail and
they had a different story some people
in success learned the wrong lesson uh I
had a guy work for me 18 years old
and he he was talented what he was doing
but he had like he'd you know like many
people do I did it 18 too I had a bit of
a degenerate streak like to gamble and
uh you know when I gamble I played
online poker kids nowadays they play
Robin Hood
and they play crypto and they play other
things right so he was like you know I'm
talking to him on a call and he goes
quiet for a second
um I hate did you are you do you hear me
like I said let's do this you're writing
the notes you stopped writing what
happened he goes oh sorry I saw that
Bitcoin crash to four thousand dollars
and I wanted to buy
and I go and I'm like two things a we're
in a meeting why are you looking at the
Bitcoin price B why is Bitcoin four
thousand I wanna buy two that's how I
win
she bought on like some crazy leverage
so he's buying like 25x or something
like that so he puts in like five grand
but buys 25x worth but like he's gonna
get liquidated if the price drops
anymore but he played that right he
makes money and so he's 18 or 19 years
old I think he's got a couple hundred
thousand dollars in the bank from like a
combination of like taking all the money
I paid him for work and then gambling
and trying to run it up
and I'm like okay that's good
um
and I'd always talked to him about this
one company so there's this company that
he uh he was really interested in that
was like whatever some gaming company
listed on the Australian stock exchange
he kept talking about this I'm like dude
do you think I care about some company
in Australia like why do you tell me
about this he's like I think it's gonna
be big so I'm like if you think it's
gonna be big you should invest in it but
I forgot that he's not a normal person
and he's going to invest everything in
it so he does he invests all of his
money into this one stock
of course things don't go right
this that company wasn't doing so well
they say they decide
um you know what shit's not going well
for us we're going to do what was in
Vogue at the time we're gonna pivot to
crypto so they go and they say we are
now a blockchain gaming company
Australian stock exchange doesn't like
that they boot them off the exchange
they say we don't support crypto
publicly traded companies so you they
de-list them so now my friend is 20
years old he's holding 200 000 of
a stock that is no longer listed on the
market and basically has no Pathway to
get back on there and just seems like a
dead end
so he joins this Facebook group of
people who also were like stockholders
like a you know like uh victims of a
victims group
and people in that group are um just
like what do we do like I own the stock
I can't even sell it anymore and so
let's not publicly traded anymore so
what do I do and so some people are
offering like look I'll buy it off you
for like you know 10 cents on the dollar
like I'll just I'll give you 10 cents
for every dollar you have of this and
people are happy to move on from their
position so my friend decides
you know what the thing I'm gonna do the
lesson I've learned so far in this like
extreme risk-taking thing is that I
didn't take enough risk he immediately
goes and doubles down on it and um
he he buys he goes and borrows more
money and starts buying up more stock
from all these people that are selling
for pennies on the dollar he becomes
like one of the largest shareholders of
this company
somehow through like dumb luck
um this company starts to uh like crypto
crypto hits a bull run crypto starts
going up now any crypto company is
looking good nfts become a thing this
company's perfectly positioned to do
something nfts
share price goes way up but it's still
delisted but it's now worth a lot so a
guy
um approaches him and says I'll give you
two million dollars for it
hold on I'm gonna take my daughter to go
pee one second that's okay all right
potty training
here I am dropping knowledge bombs and
then I have to go wipe a button potty
training the duality of man get you a
man that can do both exactly that was
the commercial right there
um
where was it okay guy comes up offers
him two million dollars for his stock
I'm like how the hell did this work out
from of course he says no he says this
is going to go bigger and he goes
forward and I'm telling the story and at
the time I told the story
I was telling it because I was like this
guy who's my intern had this crazy story
like isn't that amazing
and one gentleman at the table goes
huh he goes so do you think he learned
the right lesson out of that I had never
even heard somebody say this question
which is
did you you learned yes but did you
learn the right thing from this
experience and um I don't think I had
even learned the lesson and definitely
my friend who was the the kid who's
doing this had not learned the right
lesson which was his he was taking away
this lesson of like I'm a genius and I'm
right
um as his like takeaway when he actually
probably should have been taking away
you know a slightly different lesson and
I just see this over and over again
um and I think there's a practical part
of this too people don't write down what
they were thinking
at the time or later like they don't
really have a system in place that will
let them assess what they're doing so
you can kind of like our memories are
generally quite bad our memories of our
own thoughts are worse our memories of
our thoughts when we were wrong you're
kidding me like there's no chance we
have an accurate view of that and so
because you don't actually have this
like accurate like
I'm doing this for this reason I think
this is how it's gonna play out fast
forward here's how it actually played
out you don't have this before and after
after to learn from so I think generally
people aren't very good at learning from
this and I think it's also
um
interesting that they don't have a
system to do it and I think people
should have a system to assess the
decisions you make because judgment and
decision making
is probably the most important skill you
can hone over time but we just kind of
leave it up to like I hope it just comes
with age when actually you can probably
increase the rate of learning on your
decision making if you like establish a
little system for yourself of being
just writing things down right now while
you're doing what you're doing and why
and then assessing it later regularly
regularly assessing it I always thought
it would be really cool if there was
such a machine as being able to take a
photo of the texture of your mind and
being able to revisit it you know for
the people that are trying to become
more positive or more enthusiastic or
more balanced or Economist or or mindful
or peaceful or aggressive or overcome
their shyness whatever
go back to you five years ago you 10
years ago and
get a sense for what sorts of things
captured your attention on a daily basis
what were the sorts of things that you
were caught up ruminating about and
worrying about whether they were going
to happen or how they could have
happened or if what you would have done
had you not wanted them to happen
if you were able to go back and
experience that
literally feel it again the texture of
your mind
the contrast would be so unbelievable
but it's the drip drip drip Japanese
water torture of erosion that's so slow
like a tectonic plate moves over time
that it nudges what we expect from our
daily existence to the point where you
can't notice it when did you become
confident when did you overcome your
shiners when did you whatever like it
it's there's no point at which it
happened it's just it's like asking
someone when they became old right it's
just a gradation that you went through
when did you become peaceful when did
you become angry when did you become
resentful like all of these things they
just occur and I think that
self-deception around things that we got
wrong as you said is just it's it's
[__] I went to the doctor the other
day and I'm sitting there and I'm like
yeah I think I might have sleep apnea I
don't really know
um I did a test back in the day they
said you know it was very mild but I
feel like it's gotten worse I don't
really know and he goes um he's like
have you gained any weight and I was
like
um yeah maybe a little I don't know yeah
I think so but like not like something
drastic and it pulls up my chart and the
the doctor's office I go to it's like
the charts like in between you two so
it's not like back in the day the doctor
used to have it and they used to look at
it then talk to you here we could both
see the screen and so I'm looking at the
chart and literally he's like so 20 2017
you were 40 pounds lighter than you are
now
I was like 40 pounds that sounds like a
lot of weight to get I guess it has been
I basically gained 10 pounds a year for
eight pounds a year for five years
and it was like
um yeah I knew I'd been getting kind of
out of shape dad bod status but like uh
when you hear it that way or you see it
on a chart you're just like what like it
was eye-opening and that's me and I can
see my body imagine my brain and my
level of wisdom and the things I focus
on and my my intellect and my decision
making like I have no chance of noticing
either the degradation or or
improvements to be honest of those over
time I do wish a such a machine uh would
would exist George so again this is like
George is the third guest here uh it's
just it doesn't happen to be
contributing it's been very quiet today
he's got this thing that he's doing
which is pretty deck pulled as it goes
where at the end of each day he's trying
to capture some key lessons about the
day so that he can make the hidden
observable uh in terms of how he feels
and you know journaling is is kind of a
more qualitative solution I suppose for
this um but you know a dashboard like
what Rob is trying to design or George
has managed to Cobble together on a free
type form website or whatever it is that
he's using
um I do think it's a good way to to
start visualizing uh the things that you
care about all right next one I love
this one being a billionaire is a stupid
goal why you're around billionaires you
you're a man of of many means and do you
have friends with as many means and even
more means why
well first of all they just give the
money away anyways so clearly it
couldn't be that valuable um like they
worked their whole life to get it and
then they give it all away
um so already that tells you that like
acute massive accumulation and abundance
of money
Beyond a certain point certainly doesn't
matter otherwise they would not give it
away like let's say I gave them extra
health I don't think they're donating
that let's say I gave them extra time
100 extra years of life I don't think
they're donating that
but you can give them a billion dollars
and they'll give away 99 of it so that's
the first thing uh just the first signal
that maybe this is overrated
uh the second is
I'm not against abundance so some most
people who hate billionaires just hate
abundance they hate when anybody wins at
a large scale I'm not that guy I like
people who win I admire and respect and
you know strive to be one of those
people
but what I admire and appreciate the
most is somebody who picks the right
game to play somebody who chooses a game
or designs a game of their own liking so
um the question then becomes what are
the other things that could become
massively abundant and a massive winner
of okay the money game is one
um
and there are certainly checkpoints
along the way of money that matter when
you don't have to have any more money
like you don't have to have a job
because you have your Investments make
you enough money right that's Financial
Freedom that was like the key checkpoint
of life or it's not being in debt you
know getting back to zero for somebody
who's in debt is a big checkpoint
um but beyond that you know the
checkpoints run out or they spread out
in a big way and the the prizes shrink
um it's like what what's the difference
between somebody's got 50 million
dollars and 500 million dollars like one
rents the jet the other owns the jet
there's not that much of a difference
right uh one has a library in their
house the other guy pays for the library
at the school it's like who cares do I
really care about that anyways not worth
dedicating my life to so the question is
what things what things of abundance are
worth dedicating your life to and how do
you think about those so I think it's
great to have an abundance of Time free
time but also youth that's youthfulness
and also if you're just a young person
like when I was 21 I just wanted
everything that the 40 year olds around
me had they seem to have the money they
seem to have the relationships they seem
to have the the cars and the the status
and the the cool job and everything else
and now that I'm you know I'm 35 I'm
going to be 40 soon all I want is what
the 21 year olds have time and youth
energy abundance like Freedom like you
know and so you know youth is wasted on
the young in that way so I think having
abundance of time is amazing having an
abundance of generosity would be amazing
have an abundance of fun is amazing I
got I've figured out what to do with my
life just by simply asking the question
who is having the most fun in their
career and that was a much better
guiding principle
um for me to figure out what I actually
wanted to do with my life was look
around and figure out who's having the
most fun I knew a lot of successful
people those people were not having a
lot of fun and uh the the scary part the
most dangerous part of it all was if you
asked him are you having fun they say
yeah but if You observe them it's like
somebody whose volume knob is stuck on
seven they don't even know that there's
eight nine and ten they can only go to
seven they think seven is sufficient and
maximally fun
um once you see somebody on 10 you look
at the seven you're like ah there's a
clear difference who were the people
that were at 10.
um so there's some people that are like
of
I would say first it was sad how hard it
was to think of this because I was like
I know a bunch of people who by
traditional measures are successful and
it wasn't like I just could rattle off
20 names of people who are winning like
if you said who's winning the money game
I could name you 20 people if you said
who's winning the audience game I could
name you 20 people but if who's having
the most fun who are the people that are
dominating that'll have fun in life game
it was a lot harder for me to think of
those names which means I kind of
surrounded myself with the wrong people
the wrong inspiration
I think that Joe Rogan has a ton of fun
and he's kind of like a popular person
so it's not that cool of an answer but
what I think he's done amazingly well is
he has managed to make his life about
his Hobbies without turning his Hobbies
into jobs
so his Hobbies loves you know martial
arts
fighting UFC becomes the commentator for
the UFC gets to call all the biggest
fights sit ringside no get to know the
fighters follow the sport study it for
get paid to study this thing get paid to
watch this thing he would otherwise be
paying to watch hmm that's great but he
also avoided all the trappings of that
job he's not on the road 200 days a year
like Dana White is he doesn't have to he
literally just said I'm only gonna do
the Vegas shows which happened to be the
best shows which happened to be one hour
from where he lives you know was living
when he was in LA
um and he's like I'm not going to travel
to Abu Dhabi for with one fight it's
just not worth it right he loved comedy
he finds it creatively challenging to do
that and finds it amazing to like make
people laugh for a living he does that
and he's he has one in that game as well
um but he again doesn't have to tour 250
days a year like most comedians
it doesn't have to censor himself like
many comedians podcasting he's like oh
I'm just curious guy I'd love to have
these conversations became the number
one podcaster right
um didn't have to but what you don't see
him do is what a lot of content creators
do they get on a Content treadmill that
they don't enjoy and they're constantly
begging the begging for audience trying
to figure out what do I need to do to
get more clicks more likes more whatever
and they almost ruin what's otherwise
the best job in the world
he's managed to become the podcaster
without doing that and so he kind of
hits the goals but also what you call
the anti-goals which are basically the
traps you could fall into while
achieving your goal
um I'll never forget like a friend in
college her dad was a partner at a big
consulting firm and he was making
literally one million dollars a year and
I thought that was mind-blowing that
somebody could make one million dollars
in a year let alone like I thought
having a million dollars was like what
you accumulate over time that was the
end point of money
and he was making a million dollars a
year but he also traveled Monday through
Thursday night and he would get back
Thursday night and then be there Friday
Saturday and then Sunday he would leave
again basically travel uh for his job
and he did that her whole life and now
she's in college and he missed like
basically her her whole life and she
resented him for it and I was like wow
uh you know can you you know you want
success but you want your kids to like
you you want success but your kids
didn't know you you want success but you
want your wife to still like you and be
faithful in that relationship so like
you know Define the game a little
differently so I think being a
billionaire is a stupid goal because it
defines the game on terms that for an
abundance that doesn't actually matter
I love that are you familiar with
um die with zero Bill Perkins stuff good
book yeah I like that book yeah I became
really tight with him after I brought
him on the show he I mean you know for
anybody that doesn't like that book and
I can understand why it rubbed certain
people up the wrong way because it's a
book that's written for people who have
Surplus income and not everybody does
which means that the people who don't
have it get upset about it
here's a man that lives that philosophy
we've finished classic Case by the way
of pointing the blame the wrong way uh
you're bad at this guy who wrote This
Book
for some people uh because you're you
know you don't have what those people
have uh you know that's misguided anger
I would I would agree
um yeah we finished that podcast within
30 minutes we are on his boat being
driven by the captain of his boat wake
surfing for the next three and a half
hours with Phil the Unabomber uh
somebody somebody the poker player uh
and I'm like
and then over the next like three or
four weeks I spent a ton of time at his
house and and he just he does the things
this is related tangentially to
something that I think you've done
recently or at least I've seen someone
write about you or maybe you write about
yourself which is the life-changing
nature of having an assistant and
integrating them correctly into your
life uh what does that look like
um let me say two things one there's
only one thing I remember from the die
with zero book I read it I liked it but
I only remember one thing and it's a
story he tells about I want to tell it
again because it was so impactful to me
and I feel like everybody needs to hear
this so I'm like oh let me just say his
his bit here he talks about like he was
he had some job uh at a bank or
investment firm or something like that
like you know the job you want and um
his friend was like I want to go on a
trip to Europe for like five to six
weeks like let's go backpacking through
Europe they were like just out of school
22 22 to 25 years old something like
that he's like let's go back to Europe
and then I was like oh yeah that sounds
sounds great but like how are we gonna
get six weeks off he's like we're not
probably I will ask but they probably
won't say yes and then we'll quit and
we'll hope that there's a job for us we
can come back he's like ah man like
that's irresponsible like I don't want
to do that
so his friend goes and he's at the time
he's laughing at him like
stupid guy made stupid decision to quit
his job and go backpacking frolicking
through Europe like and he's like you
know I'm here making wise decisions that
guy's making unwise decisions
friend comes back friend is like
dude he's like how was it he's like I
mean I can't even put into words like
anybody who's done study abroad comes
back with the same thing where they're
like it's hard to even explain it was so
amazing I stayed in these hostels and I
was
um like we met this band and we just
jumped on their van and we toured with
them for two nights and then I met this
girl and she was amazing uh we're still
dating and I've tried this food and
whatever slept on the beach three to
three of the dice it was amazing he's
like wow damn he's like I knew
immediately that I had made a mistake
should have had those experiences and
second thing he says finally he's like
32 33 years old he's like has
accumulated enough Social Capital at
this company to be able to take time off
and go do this so he goes on the
backpacking trip at like 33 or 32 and
he's like
you know it's not that fun staying in a
hostel when you're 33 and like you know
it's it's different there's actually
it's not just that it would have been
better to do it then he's like there's a
time a season of life where you should
do certain things and they're really
those things have maximal impact during
those seasons and what I thought he was
doing was unwise and actually he was
doing the life-wise thing to do which
was to take advantage of our youth and
um
and go have this experience at the time
where that experience is amazing and um
I just oh that that stuck out with me I
just I feel like that is such a such a
important lesson right like what do you
want to add a an additional one in that
he hasn't released yet he has
this shows the levels of wealth we're
about to talk about your assistant this
guy's got an experienced architect who
their only job is to find different
things that they think
he might want to do
and then put them to him and then even
if he says that he doesn't want to do
them convince them that he's going to go
and do them and one of them was training
which is like inter railing in Japan and
there are these five-star very expensive
trains that go the full length of Japan
and it's like being on a cruise but
being on a like a really really
expensive train and they sent it across
to him and he said eat [__] that sounds
[__] lame I don't want to do that why
am I going on a train I've got a hot
wife like what am I I'm gonna go on this
train on my own it's gonna be full of
old people I'm gonna hate it it's gonna
be moving around and blah blah they
convinced him to go he gets on falls in
love with it he's like I want to do this
I want to do this every month for the
rest of my life what he realizes is is
that he can do that when he's 70. he
can't keep wakeboarding when he's 70. so
he is banking this anticipation for when
he's going to get back onto intervaling
or training or whatever across Japan and
God knows where else he's going to go
but that's for the future so he there
are certain experiences that you can
only do at particular periods of your
life they're better maximized during
that time it's kind of less lame to do
them during that time and it allows you
to match the uh it's a lot of it is to
do with health like health wealth and
time are the three factors that you play
with in his book
your health is largely a determinant of
what it is that you're able to do
because you like your hips aren't going
to take it skiing when you're 80 right
right but you probably find to do
training like to sit on a train and be
served like cake by by a nice Japanese
person right like that's that's that's
gonna be fine right um so yeah uh
periods yes you assistant what have you
done how's it worked
uh yeah I mean I don't even think it's
that crazy but uh I think that most
people I I I I sort of rail on these
like controversial things which is like
the common theme of all of my St all of
my beliefs comes down to the following
which is don't follow what most people
do because most people don't have a
result that you would want so like in
America most the average person is obese
literally like by the definition I think
the average was obese
um what 50 something percent of
marriages end in divorce so that's kind
of like that's the average expected
outcome there
um and Below don't have you know more
than a thousand dollars in the bank or
ten thousand dollars for you know like
an emergency whatever the numbers are
the specifics don't really matter
directionally they're all correct which
is that
it is easy to feel safe doing what most
people do until you realize that most
people
are going to a destination you don't
want to be at then it becomes very risky
to do what most people do so
um
most people when they get money buy
luxury luxurious things like fancy cars
clothes watches uh maybe vacations
things like that
and um
I have this you know and so there's this
I would say one of the general wisdoms
is experiences are greater than things
and I always say services are even
better than experiences uh like
um I was able to hire uh you know an
assistant
works full time for me for like the cost
of a couple of purses and an assistant
improves the quality of your life far
more than a person that sits in your
closet because you're afraid to take it
out and get a scratcher um same thing
with a car I hired a private Chef for
our family for less than what most
people pay for a luxury car because I
didn't care what it looked like for like
when I drove around or you know like I
like a quality car a safe car but like I
didn't care if it was an Instagram car
um but I did care that somebody would
go get fresh ingredients make healthy
food for me and my family that tastes
great and better than I can and I don't
have to worry about going getting
groceries cooking or cleaning or
cleaning up afterwards
um so I got my time I got my health and
I got my taste like I can't believe
everybody doesn't do this who can right
so um so that's the first thing
um assistant same thing hired assistant
um through Shepard she's in uh the
Philippines so I didn't even go with a
full-on personal assistant here so let
me try first let me dabble with it this
way and it's great she she's the first
line of defense on your email inbox and
your time and
um she makes me uh she helps me be a
better friend I'm like hey my friend had
this thing I think I want to give him
this gift can you go find a you know I
want to buy him a candle that has this
funny thing about this inside joke on
the front and just send it to him in a
month and also when's their birthday
let's make sure we remember that this
year because I'm kind of a shitty friend
otherwise it'll just help you be a
better person they help you be whatever
the person you want to be they can help
you be and I created a system to like to
do that so I had to learn how to even
operate uh you know with this with this
new functionality to have to have
somebody who could do this with you once
I learned it it's pretty big unlock
um but I would say just in general
finding a way to to buy luxuries that
you actually want is great I will also
say
I think for people who are sitting there
listening they're like oh great oh wow
it was great to have a private Chef an
assistant yeah good for you douchebag
right like that's fair uh take that on
the chin but I will say
I used to have a big reaction whenever I
would experience uh whenever I encounter
people who had this type of stuff it was
basically bitterness and then but it
would be disguised as
oh that's stupid I wouldn't want that
that's stuck up I would tell myself some
story that would make myself feel better
and the story was either that having
that thing would make me a bad person or
that I don't want that anyways
um for whatever reasons reasons
um
and I had this visceral experience I
went to somebody's house in Las Vegas
and they had live in like a basically a
palace and then they drive the fanciest
cars and they have literally there's a
pool that goes around their house like a
circle like a moat but it's just that's
their swimming pool it would be cooler
if it was a moat exactly it's like a
swimmable boat it's a moat you just want
to stay in instead of crops and um and I
was talking to my buddy and I was like
yeah they have all the stuff but I
wouldn't want that anyway I was being
defensive about it I didn't even realize
it he goes he goes uh you know just
gonna let you know one friend to another
uh you know like one black belt to
another trying to master we're both
trying to master our minds uh you're
you're talking very differently than you
usually do and it kind of makes me feel
like uh maybe
um
you know it's kind of bothering you that
you don't have these things and you're
telling yourself all these things about
why you don't want them anyways or why
it's bad to have them or how this
person's douchebag for having them
instead what if you switched what if
this was Costco and you got to walk
around and you're sampling a bunch of
things of a lifestyle to figure out
which ones you want and which ones you
don't and so instead of the reaction
being I don't have this and therefore I
feel bad
be like oh I'm so lucky I get to try
this to figure out if I like this how I
like this or if I don't care for this at
all fantastic what a cheap way to learn
that
um and I just flipped my mindset into
like oh I actually seek being exposed to
other ways of thinking or living in
order to get a sample a little taste a
little test to find out oh that's
awesome or hmm they do it this way but I
would want it this remix way or just oh
I don't want that at all think I don't
have to desire that because it's not
something that appeals to me and that
really changed the way I interacted with
people who I felt like because I felt uh
embarrassed at the way I was reacting
before
having a friend who calls you out in a
what sounds like reassuring but firm way
like that about your [__] is
you need to keep those sorts of people
close to you well we made an agreement
it was like hey look I want to be this
way you want to be this way we're both
nerds about this stuff so let's make an
agreement that
um in our quest to master this to become
a black belt uh there are going to be
times where you're going to have to
point out techniques I'm doing wrong
things I'm doing and I agree so uh I
want you
to just say them to me when you see him
and I promise you that I will receive it
as a gift the feedback is a gift and I
will receive it that way
um so that's that's the agreement we're
both going to do that for each other
that's part of who we're both
like-minded this way so we know we can
talk to each other about that whereas if
we talk to the wrong person who's not
seeking that type of input or uh or
opinion they might take it out the wrong
way but uh let's set an agreement a
foundation right now we are men who want
to live by a certain code that's our
code and uh we both are down with this
crowdsourcing your personal growth I
like it very much Sean Puri ladies and
gentlemen dude I'm so glad that we got
to run this back the first one was
phenomenal and I want to do this again
so please keep on coming up with
controversial tactics for people to have
a better life where should people go to
keep up to date with all of the
different things that you do
uh yeah you can go to just uh my my
email list is where I put I think the
best content so just go to seanpuri.com
s-h-a-n-p-u-r-i.com uh you can put the
link in there whatever um and just put
your email in there I send out uh stuff
that I think is the most thoughtful
stuff that's hopefully Gonna Make You
uh make you think is really all my only
promise I I think I I can spark thoughts
in your head
um and then the second thing is the
podcast so we have a podcast called my
first million uh you know if people
listen to this podcast probably to
become more wise most people listen to
this podcast are our podcast to become
wealthy and so
um yeah it's me and my buddy Sam it's a
good time it's very entertaining and
it's kind of about business and
opportunities that we see uh or stories
that we hear that you know we get to
share uh on the Pod so my first million
go subscribe to that oh yeah Sean I
appreciate you thank you man thank you
if you enjoyed that episode then press
here for a selection of the best clips
from the podcast over the last few weeks
and don't forget to subscribe